sitting here today
do you know how much
money
ms heard has actually donated to the
aclu actually remitted to the aclu
um i that would be
350 dollars paid directly
how much
has been paid indirectly and credited
to ms hurt
um there was one hundred thousand
dollars um which was a check from johnny
depp
there was a five thousand five hundred
thousand dollar payment from
a donor advised fund at vanguard
and then there was a 350 000 payment
that appears to be from a donor-advised
fund at fidelity
making it total 1.3 is the is the amount
the 100 000 payment we received a check
from
johnny depp's um
representatives and it was said to be
a payment in connection with um on
behalf of amber hurd
she confirmed that
when we initially um uh had contact with
amber heard in 2016
she indicated her desire to pay 3.5
million dollars to the aclu
so it's fair to say that she has not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu true that's true we believe
that that is a
donor-advised fund that was set up by
elon musk and isn't he also a donor to
the aclu foundation in his own right
yes there were communications back and
forth between the aclu and ms heard
including um a thank you acknowledgement
letter that mr
was sent under mr romero's name to
miss herd thanking her for the 350 000
contribution um noting that um that
it was part of her intention to make a
um 3.5 million dollar contribution to
the aclu and mr romero attached to that
communication a standard aclu pledge
form we were aware
very early on
that the
her intention to contribute the 3.5
million dollars to us was half of
her 7 million
divorce proceedings we understood that
the other 3.5 million dollars the other
half was going to
a children's hospital in los angeles